bonsoir et bienvenue sur TVfil 78 pour
une nouvelle semaine d'actualité locale
d'information locale et aujourd'hui 19
janvier 2015 il sera question de cette
centaine de soldats déployés dans les
ivelines afin d'éviter les actes
antisémites le préfet a rencontré samedi
les fidèles de la communauté de
Versailles demain mardi l'université de
Versailles 50 ans nveline se penche sur
la liberté de la presse avec une
conférence autour du rôle de la
caricature depuis la 3e république une
mise en perspective historique de
l'actualité et puis à saint-cir l'école
pour les élections départementales de
mars les anciens alliés du partis
socialiste ont décidé de faire une liste
commune invité jean-lve Maximilien le
responsable du Front de gauche sur ce
canton le Centre d'histoire culturel des
sociétés contemporaines de l'Université
de Versailles SaintQuentin propose donc
demain mardi une conférence sur le le
thème liberté de la presse et caricature
dans la France républicaine nous sommes
en ligne avec Christian Delport
vice-président à la recherche et au
développement scientifique de
l'université professeur d'histoire
contemporaine spécialiste de l'histoire
des médias et du journalisme bonsoir
Christian Delport bonsoir vous êtes à
l'origine notamment de ce rendez-vous
vous vouliez aller au-delà de l'émotion
et proposer une perspective historique
au débats et aux discussions d'actualité
il fallait mettre en perspective un
petit peu ce qui se joue aujourd'hui oui
nous sommes dans université dans C unité
il y a l'émotion mais également la
raison il y a la réflexion et en fait
euh mon propos est d'essayer de remettre
un petit peu en perspective tous les
débats que nous avons en ce moment
autour de la liberté d'expression en
essayant de comprendre d'où vient cette
liberté acquise par la caricature depuis
plus d'un siècle h la caricature
justement en France depuis la 3e
république ce sera l'objet de la
conférence de demain mais quel est quel
a été son rôle justement à cette
caricature dans la liberté dans
l'expression de la liberté de la presse
d'abord elle a été son rôle a été
capitale dans l'acquisition de la de la
liberté de la presse hein sous la
monarchie à l'époque de domier et puis
plus tard surous le Second Empire les
caricaturistes d'ailleurs ont payé de
leur personne ils ont été souvent
condamnés et emprisonnés
pour lutter pour cette liberté
d'expression et puis sous la sous la
République ils ont toujours été euh les
faire de lance de de la liberté de la
presse on a tout de même l'impression
que ces derniers temps la caricature
intéressait peu en tout cas en tout cas
moins les lecteur et que le public a
redécouvert un petit peu la caricature
et et son rôle véritablement important
c'est le sentiment que vous avez
aujourd'hui lorsque vous voyez tout le
monde se se ruer notamment sur la la
publication Charlie Hebdo ou brandir les
caricatures ou s'y référer c'est assez
paradoxal parce que depuis 20 25 ans le
dessin de presse audà de la caricature a
disparaît peu à peu des journaux euh euh
chariette d'eau c'est un une exception
dans le paysage de la presse française
et d'ailleurs de la presse européenne de
manière générale parce que lorsque vous
regardez les les les les journaux du euh
les quotidiens les hebdomadaires euh il
y a encore 30 ans il y avait beaucoup de
dessins aujourd'hui il y en a
pratiquement plus euh les dessinateurs
sont sont une centaine à peu près qui
arrivent à vivre de leur crayon ça n'est
c'est peu de choses mais évidemment euh
l'impact de la caricature est beaucoup
plus important que sa sa diffusion sous
forme papier parce que la caricature
c'est c'est de l'émotion c'est c'est ce
sont des choses très très très très très
prignante dans la dans la fibre
populaire et puis aujourd'hui cette
caricature au-delà de de la version de
papier circule circule beaucoup grâce à
Internet et au réseaux sociaux une
dernière question Charo qui tire plus de
7 millions d'exemplaires son numéro de
de mercredi dernier vous réagissez
comment bah justement là on est sous le
coup de de l'émotion c'est un c'est un
moment très particulier de l'histoire de
la presse française jamais un journal
n'a été diffusé à 7 millions
d'exemplaires les les record jusqu'à
présent c'était autour de 2 millions
2500000 pour des événements très très
particuliers ce qu'il faut c'est au-delà
de cette émotion et bien que le journal
vive il faut savoir qu' avant avant
l'attentat avant ce ce massacre il n'y
avait diffusé que 30 à 4000 exemplaires
de charlieo donc redécouvrons ce journal
redécouvrons la caricature et n
participons à au combat pour jamais
gagner pour la liberté de la presse
merci Christian delpte conférence donc
demain mardi 14h30 université de
Versailles 51 nous en parlerons bien sûr
dans notre prochaine édition nous y
serons présents en attendant je vous
laisse découvrir notre question du jour
liberté de la presse peut-on tout dire
vos
réponses oui enin on peut tout dire à
partir du moment où ou ça choquerait pas
le public et ça dépend de chaque
personne chaque personne le mot liberté
signifie pas forcément la même chose
pour moi je pense qu'on peut tout dire
après celui qui qui qui veut pas
entendre il a qu'à regarder ailleurs il
y en a plein de il y a plein de journaux
non quand ça blesse les gens non je
m'autorise pas laisser les gens je vois
pas pourquoi d'autres personnes au N
d'une liberté blisseraiit d'autres
personnes et son de respect et quand le
respect n'est plus là la liberté n'a
plus de sens moi je pense que oui bah on
est quand même dans un pays où on peut
s'exprimer après c'est à chaque personne
disons de de penser ce qu'il veut sinon
si on nous interdit d'interdire on fait
quoi nous restons sur ces événements
tragique de ce début d'année les sites
de la communauté juive des ivelines
notamment font l'objet d'une protection
particulière de la part des militaires
exemple devant la synagogue de
Versailles le préfet s'est d'ailleurs
rendu en personne ce weekend Catherine
zulato des militaires du 152e régiment
d'infanterie de Colmar en faction devant
la synagogue de Versailles c'était ce
samedi matin et depuis ce weekend ce
sont en tout 11 sites principaux de la
communauté juive dans le département qui
font l'objet d'une surveillance
particulière de la part de l'armée
crèche école et lieu de culte le préfet
a d'ailleurs rencontré Samuel Sandler le
président de la communauté versaill pour
expliquer le dispositif est rassuré sur
chacun des sites il y a une équipe de 12
militaires qui se relaent pour assurer
une permanence
H24 et pour protéger la communauté et
rassurer la communauté notre objectif
c'est de dire à la communauté qu'on est
bien sûr avec elle dans ces moments
difficiles et douloureux et qu'on lui
donne les moyens de sa sécurité vous
savez que les les attentats ont ciblé
fortement la communauté juive au moment
notamment de des
TR très des très graves très graves
actions de de l'hyper cacher à Paris
donc la communauté juive se
sent vraiment meurtrie les 11 lieux
faisant l'objet d'une surveillance
particulière se situe notamment à
Versailles mais aussi comme ici à MPa
d'autres villes sont concernées poigné
la forêt et un peu plus loin poissi
Sartrouville ou encore Saint-Germain au
lait ce mardi le préfet des ivelines
rassemblera tous les chefs d'équipe afin
de faire le point sur le dispositif est
présenté une feuille de route il sera
aussi question de l'organisation des
rapports entre militaire police
nationale et police municipale le plan
vigip pirate alerte attentat mobilise
10000 militaires en France 6000 rien que
sur l'île- de- France et 132 dans les
ivelines une réaction à présent celle de
Jamel de Bou le natif de Trapp s'est
exprimé suite aux événements hier soir
sur l'antenne de TF1 il a évoqué sa
religion mais aussi sa famille et sa
vision de la France il se dit
particulièrement meurtrie écoutez
j'ai passé mon temps à pas dire que
j'étais musulman pas parce que j'en
étais pas fier loin de là parce que je
je considérais que c'était pas un sujet
qu'on avait pas besoin d'affirmer son
identité sa différence qu'on était tous
pareil c'est peut-être un peu utopique
aujourd'hui je me dis mais mais c'est
vrai j'ai j'ai j'ai jamais eu besoin de
le faire aujourd'hui j'ai presque besoin
de le revendiquer comme pour dire ne
vous inquiétez pas on est pareil malgré
nos différences je je suis
français musulman artiste je suis n à
Barb j'ai grandi à trappe je su père de
deux enfants Maria une une chrétienne
journaliste très très belle et et ça
pour moi c'est la France il y a eu 200
incidents d'enfants qui n'ont pas voulu
respecter la la le de silence qu'est-ce
que vous dites à ces à ces enfantsl je
dit que c'est complètement débile que
c'est irrespectueux que ça ne se fait
pas de ne pas respecter les morts on ne
se comporte pas comme ça c'est sans
précédent ce qui est arrivé c'est arrivé
c'est arrivé au cœur de la capitale et
ça concerne tout le monde et tout le
monde a été touché tout le monde a été
meurtrri par ce qui s'est passé c'est
gamin là c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
éduqués
ne sont pas encadrés ou ne sont tout
simplement pas aimés une autre
information qui concerne Versailles où
un homme de 87 ans s'est fait voler 200
€ et les clés de sa maison vendredi
dernier trois faux policiers sont
parvenus à s'introduire chez lui en
prétextant vouloir arrêter un autre
homme venu lui se présenter à sa porte
pour proposer de réaliser des travaux de
jardinage les quatre complices sont
toujours recherchés par les services de
police politique les cérémonies de veux
se poursuivre en ce mois de janvier pour
les élus vendredi dernier c'est le maire
de en cours qui s'est adressé à ses
homologues aux responsables d'entreprise
ou encore chef d'association un discours
très porté sur les questions
économiques fidèle à son habitude eff
forort de son nouveau statut de premier
adjoint en charge des questions
économiques à l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin le maire des lancour l'UMP
Jean-Michel Fourgous a mis l'accent lors
de son discours pour la nouvelle année
sur les entreprises saluant le travail
de ses dirigeants face au choix jugé
mauvais du gouvernement un discours
également empreint donc d'inquiétude
avec la chute des dotations de l'État 3
millions d'euros en moins et c'est le
projet d'aménagement de la colline desé
lancours ou encore la rénovation du
gymnase Lionel Teré qui sont gelés
François Hollande plusqu gratinier avec
une nouvelle charge contre les rythmes
scolaires mesures coûteuses et inutiles
selon le premier magistrat de la ville
lui qui préfère rappeler les efforts
réalisé à hencour pour le développement
du numérique entre TNI et tablette pas
d'annonce à proprement parl pour cette
nouvelle année mais un souhait exprimé à
la fin de la cérémonie faire desl
encours un modèle d'innovation et
d'exemplarité on passe à présent aux
élections départementales 22 29 mars
prochain je reçois jean-y Maximilien
bonsoir vous êtes le responsable du
Front de gauche sur le canton de
saint-ir l'école et vous avez décidé de
rejoindre Europe Écologie Les Verts le
Parti communiste le Parti de Gauche et
nouvelle donne également pour la
campagne qui va s'ouvrir une alliance
sans le Parti socialiste pourquoi
euh y il y a pas eu d'alliance avec le
Parti socialiste au premier
tour depuis très longtemps pour ces
élections cantonales que que ce soit en
2011 que ce soit en 2004 il n'y avait
pas d'alliance au premier tour avec le
le Parti socialiste aujourd'hui le
contexte est un peu différent en très
différent à vrai dire dans la mesure où
que ce soit au niveau national ou que ce
soit au niveau départemental on subit le
la population subit une austérité
importante grandissante et l'ensemble de
ces partis ont appelé à une
manifestation le 15 novembre euh pour
une alternative à l'austérité et donc
suite à ce rassemblement nous avons
décidé de nous rassembler également au
niveau départemental sur le canton de de
saint-sillan quels sont les sujets qui
bloquent avec le Parti socialiste même
si vous nous dites que ce n'est pas
inédit que il a toujours été comme ça au
premier tour de ne pas voir d'alliance
avec les les socialistes on pourrait
dire qu'effectivement le contexte est un
peu différent que la gauche est mise à
mal ces derniers temps et que l'UMP a
progressé est revenu dans le jeu que le
frond national aussi a fortement
progressé on pourrait imaginer dès le
premier tour cette union de la gauche
pour faire barrage aussi à la droite à
l'extrême droite alors je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on on doit comment dire
redonner de de l'espoir dans une vie
meilleur pour les populations du du
canton et de et au niveau national et
que le Parti socialiste au niveau
national ou même d'ailleurs dans les
dans le dans le canton n'a pas fait la
preuve
de de cet espoir qu'il a promis mais
qu'il n'a pas tenu et donc en en
décrétant cette politique d'austérité
depuis l'élection de 2012 on voit bien
qu'au contraire il il bloque il il il
enterre les l'espoir de tout le monde et
je pense que c'est aussi en partie pour
ça que l'on que l'on voit cette montée
du Front
national où les gens sont je
dirais comment dire pris entre plusieurs
feux
et ne ne p pouvant pas ne pouvant pas
cautionner ni la droite ni le Front
national ni ni le PS pardon s'engage
dans vers le Front national nous ce que
l'on veut justement dire en s'exprimant
dans ce cas dans ce rassemblement c'est
qu'il y a une autre voie possible contre
l'austérité et pour la fraternité
également dans la mesure
où bon nos nos valeurs c'est ce c'est
exactement les valeurs que l'on veut
défendre ça va se traduire comment
concrètement les points que vous allez
mettre en avant pendant cette cette
campagne sous cette bannière commune
alors euh concrètement le département
des Yvelines c'est un département riche
euh il est un des plus riches de France
avec de fortes disparités avec de fortes
disparités il est vrai euh mais pour
autant si on compare par rapport à
d'autres départements voisins les le
valde mararne qui est à peu près une
population équivalente 100000 habitants
en gros euh d'un côté on a on a
pratiquement 300 millions de budget
supplémentaires qui est qui est généré
dans le valde Marne au profit des
populations que dans les ivlines c'est
énorme on voit bien par
exemple un exemple pour les
collèges le le budget du valdemarne est
le double que celui des
Yvelines là on voit bien qu'il y a des
disparités qui son priorités les
priorités ne sont pas mises au bon
endroit exactement c'est ces disparités
sont sont vraéellement politiques la
politique du notamment du valde mararne
est de de miser sur le soutien aux
familles le soutien au service public et
ce qui n'est pas le cas du tout dans
dans les malgré un très faible
endettement et donc il y a des
possibilités il y a des moyens
financiers pour le département d' ziline
un axe prioritaire nous on est dans un
canton qui englobe on va
dire qui qui chevauche la plaine de
versaill et euh dans cette plaine il y a
des je dirais comment dire du potentiel
euh de développement notamment en ce qui
concerne l'agriculture et le
développement de production locale pour
permettre
de bah de d'alimenter la population
proche euh nous voulons aussi mettre en
avant le développement des des services
publics notamment en ce qui concerne les
transports euh on est dans un dans un
carrefour important à à sinsir notamment
et on a une une gare qui rayonne sur une
une partie importante du département et
et en fin de compte elle est
complètement saturée notamment de
voiture donc nous défendons l'idée qu'il
faut peut-être un pôle multimodal de
façon à drainer vers cette gare des bus
ce qui désengorgerait bien sûr les voies
de circulation automobile et qui
faciliterait la vie de de de tout le
monde le canton de saint-cir qui couvre
aussi Bois d'Arcy et Villepreux he pour
bien resituer les les comm saint-cir
Villepreux Fontenet Fontenet ré moulin
et chavenet voilà pour les différentes
communes si vous résidez sur ces villes
voilà pour le le canton en plus il y a
eu des redécoupages dans le département
tout cela est peut-être un peu confus
pour les électeurs qui des fois ont
aussi du mal à se mobiliser juste pour
en revenir à à cette campagne le duo
socialiste qui sera présenté d'ici la la
fin de la semaine ce sera Jean-Philippe
my Fabienne gelgon pour qui représentera
Villepreux notamment Jean-Philippe my
qui est le le candidat sortant sur ce ce
canton vous avez échangé avec lui déjà
justement sur cette volonté sur ce
manque d'alliance est-ce quez vous
rapprocher il devait il devait me
reconacter on s'était croisé au 11
novembre il devait me reconacter il m'a
pas recontacté donc bon j'en d que
peut-être il avait pas il prouvait pas
le besoin de me recontacter bon vous
attendez le soir du premier tour pour
voir un petit peu comment vous
positionne alors
écoutez moi je pense que le
rassemblement que l'on défend sera au
deuxème tour des élections cantonales
nous nous avons donc alors évidemment
bien sûr il sera temps de de discuter
avec Jean-Philippe Maly mais euh ce qui
s'est passé ces deux derniers mandats
est emblématique de ce que l'on ne veut
pas nous euh dans ce rassemblement c'est
que les élus fassent je dirais leur
mandat sans en référer aux électeurs en
2004 donc j'étais candidat et au premier
tour et nous avons discuté au second
tour de notre soutien au candidat
Jean-Philippe my je pardon Claude Villet
à l'époque nous avions assorti notre
notre accord d'un certain nombre de de
points qu'il devait intégrer dans son
dans son programme ce qu'il a fait le
problème c'est qu'on n pas vu
concrètement la réalisation de ces
points durant les 6 ans les 7 ans
d'ailleurs puisque ce mandat a duré 7
ans même topo je peux dire pour en 2011
quand nous
avons été candidat le Front de gauche a
été éit candidat et au deème tour il a
fallu discuter avec Jean-Philippe
malesque aussi qui était titulaire et là
aussi les les différents points sur
lequels on était tompé d'accord n'ont
pas été mis en œuvre par Jean-Philippe
my donc je pense que c'est de la
responsabilité d'un élu d'une part de
tenir ses engagements et d'autre part
d'en référer à la population
qu'il qu'il prétend comment dire
représenter et et ça n'a pas été fait ni
en 2004 ni en 2011 ni depuis mais vous
nous dites votre rassemblement sera au
second tour ça veut dire que vous misez
sur un très bon résultat puisque la
participation est en général faible et
pour qu'il y ait une triangulaire il
faudrait qu'il y ait une forte
participation pour que tous les partis
s'y retrouvent là vous pensez pouvoir
être en mesure de passer même devant le
Parti socialiste alors le problème il
est pas tellement de passer devant le
Parti socialiste le problème il est de
rassembler les les électeurs sur un
programme réellement à gauche et de
faire en sorte que que ce ce programme
devienne
majoritaire évidemment c'est pas
évidemment rien n'est gagné d'avance
hein ça c'est évident mais je dirais que
on a comme ligne de mire ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en Grèce siriza est au
portes du pouvoir on peut dire il y a
des élections en Grèce le 25 janvier
Ciza est un parti qui a 4 5 ans il y a 4
5 ans il faisait pas grand-chose et il
est né dura remblement de différentes
forces politiques de gauche qui
voulaient une alternative aux politiques
austéritaires qui était mené en Grèce à
l'époque par alternativement le Parti
socialiste ou le Parti démocrate de
droite votre justement votre adversaire
sur cette campagne là qui va s'engager
c'est le parti socialiste ou c'est l'UMP
qui sera représenté notamment par le
maire de boisarcy Philippe
benasa les deux nous
nous l'adversaire il est clairement à
droite ça il y a pas de souci là-dessus
le le nous ce que l'on défend c'est
comme je disais une alternative de
gauche euh aujourd'hui si
euh comment dire moi je peux je peux pas
penser que Jean-Philippe my qui a eu qui
a fait un mandat qui était je dirais
très très peu visible
puisse re représenter l'ensemble de la
gauche correctement pour ses futurs ce
futur mandat je pense que en effet ce
rassemblement que l'on crée aujourd'hui
qui est basé sur des des vraies valeurs
de de gauche euh de progrès de
fraternité
euh sera en capacité de rassembler
largement au-delà de ce que représentent
les partis assemblé aujourd'hui et je
pense que euh une bonne partie des
électeurs socialistes qui ne se
retrouvent pas dans euh les politiques
nationales du Parti socialiste la
politique est également faite localement
pourrait se retrouver
dans et bien sûr j'appelle euh toutes
les toutes les forces politiques de
gauche et toutes les personnalités et et
citoyens qui pensent défendre ses
valeurs à nous rejoindre bien sûr et les
noms de ces candidats pour incarner ce
programme ne sont pas encore connus
puisque vous allez bientôt vous réunir
les différentes instances VO je dis on
on décidera de l'ensemble de nos quatre
candidats parce que nous on pense que la
puisque'il y a la possibilité d'avoir
deux titulaires
de nous serons quatre candidats vous
serez donc quatre candidats mener cette
campagne même si en cas de victoire il y
en a que deux qui vont siéger hein pour
bien repréciser tout de même les choses
et les règles telles qu'elles sont
définies aujourd'hui merci Jean
Maximilien responsable Front de Gauche
donc à saincir l'école toujours
concernant les départementales mais sur
le canton de morpa Chevreuse cette
fois-ci le même cas de figure se
retrouve les forces de gauche ne
parviennent pas à faire l'union avec les
socialistes le collectif AutreMonde de
manilé Hamo a rejoint Europe Écologie
Les Verts le Parti de Gauche le Parti
communiste des alliés qui espèrent
mettre à mal le PS et ne craignent pas
de favoriser une victoire facile de la
droite
pour faire l'alliance avec le Parti
socialiste il faudrait qu'on soit
d'accord avec beaucoup de choses sur la
politique qu' conduit al pour
l'instant je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
dans les gens qui se sont réunis
aujourd'hui beaucoup de points d'accord
avec la politique qui est suivie
aujourd'hui sur les questions
environnementales comme sur les
questions sociales comme sur les
questions économiques voire sur les
questions de la paix les grandes lignes
sur lesquelles nous bâtirons notre
proposition c'est d'une part de
travailler au niveau du département pour
la transition écologique et deuxièmement
pour réduire les les inégalités sociales
dans notre département en développant
notamment les services public santé le
deuxième patient avoir reçu le cœur
artificiel Carmat en août dernier se
porte bien la société française basée
dans les evveline annonce qu'il a quitté
l'hôpital en début d'année pour regagner
son domicile après le décès du premier
pass patient et la suspension du
protocole durant quelques semaines
celui-ci se poursuit finalement deux
autres malades devraient être opérés
avant que les résultats définitifs ne
soient publiés un mot de sport et du
rugby après la défaite à reins le Sky
rugby avait l'occasion de se relancer
avec la réception de la lanterne rouge
bon œil ce weekend très brouillons les C
contintinois gagnent mais sans la
manière le résumé d'Antony
reche les matchs entre un candidat à la
montée et une équipe condamnée à la
relégation sont souvent des pièges pour
les favoris et face à bonœil le Sky
rudby est tombé dans la tenaille
pourtant tout avait bien démarré pour
les joueurs de Guillaume paayen qui
avait ouvert le score sur un essai
collectif des avants mais alors que le
Sky maîtrise plutôt bien son sujet le
tournant du match arrive peu avant la
mi-temps coupable d'une faute d'antijeux
volontaire le deuxième ligne de bonœil
écope logiquement d'un carton jaune qui
se transforme en rouge pour contestation
les joueurs du valdeemar vont devoir
jouer plus de la moitié du match à 14
contre 15 et c'est à partir de cette
expulsion que le Sky rugby va entrer
dans un faux rythme multipliant les
fautes de main et les imprécisions les
cinquantinois se font peur et voir
revenir bonœil au score même à 13 contre
15 il aura fallu attendre les toutes
dernières minutes de jeu pour voir David
Martini plonger dans l'en but suite à ce
ballon porté des avants avant une
dernière banderille de Jérémy Barbier à
la 80e minute qui scellerlera le succès
du Sky rugby 27 à 14 le club sese à la
2e place mais sur la pelouse de
Montmorency lors de la prochaine journée
il faudra montrer un tout autre visage
pour rester dans la course à la montée
je sais pas pourquoi parce que enfin il
y a plus d'espace V qu'ils sont à 14
depis pendant plus d'une mi-temps et
même quand ils sont à 13 on narrive pas
à enchaîner on fait à nouveau des passe
quand faut garder le ballon on fait des
mauvais passes des mauvaises réceptions
et plein d'erreurs techniques qui fait
qu'au final les erreurs techniques bah
font qu'on arrive pas à scorer quoi
jamais donc donc jusqu'à la fin ils y
croient ils peuvent prendre un bonus
défensif et encore une fois on est bien
content d'être avec le Off à la fin
c'était vraiment pas croyable quoi c'est
la fin de ce journal rendez-vous demain
mardi aux mêmes horaires pour les de
l'actualité locale tout de suite sur TV
fil vous avez rendez-vous avec le 78
sport proposé présenté préparé par
Antony
re